- Thanks, Mason.
Can I get a high-five?
(record scratching)
So that's me.
And yep, that's the yodeling
Walmart boy dabbing.
You're probably wondering how I got here.
(tape squealing)
(fun country music)
Hey guys, it's Hal, I'm
here at BuzzFeed New York.
If you haven't seen in the past few days,
this video of a boy yodeling in Walmart
has gone crazy viral.
People are remixing it,
putting funny captions on it,
it's hysterical, and I am
obsessed with this video.
This boy is awesome at yodeling.
Walmart just tweeted that Mason Ramsey,
the yodeling Walmart boy,
is going to have a live
concert at the Walmart
where the video was taken.
- Join me for a special concert
at Harrisburg Walmart store.
Can't wait to see you there.
- The concert is tomorrow
and I have to go.
I'm obsessed with this video,
I have to go, I need to go.
So tomorrow morning I am
headed to Harrisburg, Illinois
to see the yodeling Walmart boy
perform live at the Walmart.
(alarm beeps)
Alright you guys, it's 6:45 in the morning
on Wednesday, April 11th.
Today is the day that my dreams come true.
Have you heard of the
yodeling Walmart boy?
Oh, you haven't heard about this?
Okay.
(laughter)
The flight isn't too bad but
there's a drive afterwards.
(bluegrass music)
(plane engine)
Okay, so we made it to St.
Louis, we just touched down,
we have about a two and a
half hour drive to Harrisburg?
I'm here with (laughs)
I'm here with Dorsey.
He's along for the ride, too.
I need some high quality
yodeling today from our boy.
We got the car.
Don't know much about Illinois,
don't know much about Harrisburg,
but I can guarantee there's some
good live music at the Walmart today.
We made it to Harrisburg
and we're headed to Walmart.
You can really tell the community
is like, pumped for this.
After a full day of
travel, we have officially
made it to the Walmart
in Harrisburg, Illinois.
The crowd is out, you guys.
Holy Moly.
Everyone's getting these
yellow Mason Ramsey T-shirts,
which is amazing.
And in about an hour, Mason
Ramsey's gonna come out
on that stage and yodel for us.
This is a true dream come true.
Okay, we just got word that
DJ Suede is going to be
performing and if you're
not familiar with DJ Suede,
he's the DJ that remixed
the Walmart yodel boy song.
This is unreal.
My day just keeps getting
better and better.
- [DJ Suede] I am DJ Suede, The Remix God.
- [Hal] When did you first see the meme,
or first see the video?
- I seen Mason's video maybe
about a week and a half ago.
And then all of my followers,
they blowin' me up, DMing
me, inboxing me, like
"Yo, DJ Suede, you gotta remix it.
"This kid is awesome."
And I did, and I'm so glad I did.
Almost a million views on my
youtube, so many followers.
I'm gettin' to see Mason grow.
He's an incredible, talented, gifted kid.
I get new fans all the time
but this is just another level
of just new fans, new people,
and I'm just loving every second of it.
- [Hal] Okay, thanks DJ.
Appreciate it, yeah.
- Thank you, man.
- Good luck out there.
- Absolutely.
- [Hal] Okay, you guys,
I made it to the stage.
This is right here, where
he's gonna be performing.
Look at this crowd.
This crowd in Harrisburg is
pretty rowdy, pretty good.
- [Hal] Can you tell us who you are?
- Yeah, I will, yeah.
- Go for it.
- Hi, I'm John McPeek,
the mayor of Harrisburg,
Illinois, and we're here
for the Mason Ramsey concert
here at our fabulous Walmart
in Harrisburg, and I'm
gonna do a proclamation
declaring Wednesday, April
11th, 2018, Mason Ramsey Day.
I'm really proud of Mason and his family
for what they've done for our community.
- Okay, I think Mason's about to come out,
which I am very excited about.
(on-stage announcer mumbling)
(distant indistinct music)
- [Announcer] I think it's
about time to bring on stage,
Ladies and gentlemen, put
your hands together for,
(audience roars)
(high-pitched screaming)
Mason Ramsey!
- Mason, yeah how you doing buddy?
- Doin' good.
- Let me ask you, what does
it feel like to be right here
with this crowd in everywhere
across the world now?
- I love it.
(audience shouts)
- Ladies and gentlemen, performing live
in the parking lot of Walmart
in Harrisburg, Illinois,
put your hands together for Mason Ramsey.
(audience howls)
(acoustic guitar music)
- It's happening.
♪ All I do is sit and sigh, "Oh Lord" ♪
♪ But I'm nobody's sugar daddy now ♪
♪ I got the lovesick blues ♪
(audience roars)
(announcer shouts indistinctly)
(soft music)
- Okay, you guys, the show just ended.
It was awesome, Mason did a great job.
But everyone's just standing
around waiting for him
to come meet and greet his fans.
I think we're gonna go get to meet him
and talk to him about how he became
the yodeling Walmart boy.
Mason, can you tell me how it felt
to be up on that stage today?
- It felt really good.
It was exciting.
My fans really help me a lot.
Thank you all for coming,
I had a great time.
- Yeah.
- Hope you had a great time too.
- What do you have to say to
all of the people who know
and love you out in the world and who are
watching your videos and
listening to your music?
- Say thank you for helping me,
and listening to Hank because
Hank is what made most of the stars.
- Aw man, thanks Mason.
Can I get a high-five?
(man laughing)
- Oh my God!
(crowd hoots)
Mason just dabbed!
Can we do one more time?
(laughter)
- Yeah Mason!
Amazing.
♪ Money in the bank, money in the bank ♪
♪ Everything is to put money in the bank ♪
(Mason shouts)
(laughter)
- Yes, Mason!
- Alright, let's go!
- Okay, I made my dreams come true.
I met Mason, the yodeling Walmart boy.
It's been a long day but
it's been a great day.
This was awesome.
Thanks Walmart, thanks Mason.
You're a freakin' star.
Okay, bye.
(twangy bluegrass music)